we have some good vibes courtesy of
austin butler yes so on wednesday austin
was on the tonight show with jimmy
fallon to promote his upcoming film
elvis and of course jimmy had to do some
impersonations of elvis at the various
points in his career yeah it's so good
jimmy also got a little dance lesson
from austin all right and honestly it's
it's the icing on the cake take a look
goodbye everyone
and it's been a long time so take it
easy on the internet but uh
i uh all right so like
like an example is uh when he was 19 and
he goes on the louisiana hayride it's
1954.
and his voice you know he's nervous his
voice at that time you speak a lot
faster when you're nervous and and also
he was young and so his voice at that
point was like uh
uh well i'd like to say how happy we are
to be down here it's a real honor for us
to get a chance to appear on louisiana
hey right yeah it's like that
[Applause]
and then like a couple years later he's
21 it's 1956. and he honestly this one i
thought of earlier because it's how i
feel right now it's that thing where
you're not sleeping at night you're just
buzzing i can't believe i just i got to
take a second i'm on jimmy fallon
talking about playing elvis presley like
you're my hero
i uh
it blows my mind
like i just yeah so at this point so
he's 21 and at that point he's more like
he says uh
uh because he's asked
what are you thinking about at night and
he says well uh well um
everything's happening so fast in the
last year and a half till uh
i'm all mixed up you know i mean i can't
keep up with everything that's happening
yeah it doesn't say that yeah
uh
and then for like a juxtaposition like
we could fast forward to 72. like
there's this great interview in 72 and
one of the first things he says is uh
uh well because at this point his voice
goes more forward into his face you know
and so then he's like uh
uh
well uh uh you know i i
well he just came out here from memphis
and uh that that sort of thing yeah he
says coming out it comes out of the
front of you it's like three different
characters from the 50s you had this one
that was really uh
fun i just called it the sidewinder
because you can kind of you can go from
walking into a side
right here basically what you're doing
is like you know when you move like this
okay
but yeah you're going to put all your
weight on your right foot and then your
left foot's just going to sort of tap so
you go to the side first and then from
there you just tap to the side
but you use this uh almost like a
windmill a windmill okay ready and this
this hand can almost be like you're
holding a cane or something okay so kind
of from the side
that's right he's the best